[Music]
[Music]
hey
everybody we're back once again we're
back everybody's asking about dennis i
fixed dennis
here he is yeah he's he's
back to his old self he's got a little
hairline fracture going around his neck
but i could actually
paint that i told him we should put like
a little neck brace on him or something
that would be really good yeah
but that that should hold it that stuff
there is [ __ ] badass stuff that that
that epoxy doesn't even belong in the
united states a motorcycle dealer
that i know that i mess with online
sometimes we
kind of trade [ __ ] he sent me some of
that stuff from his little dealership
service came in two uh
two tubes just chinese writing on them
man that shit's [ __ ] bad news if you
get that on you
and you touch the tube if you get any of
it on you it'll burn you
that's how [ __ ] powerful that stuff
is that should hold it
well i hope so and it [ __ ] smells
damn
he's gonna have to like refrain from
physical activity for a little
while oh no it's fully it's no serial
killing for a while
it should be fully cured now that's on
the doctor's orders yes
discharge
i'm gonna paper a little set of those
too yeah if you hear any noise in the
background like literally two seconds
before
we started recording like somebody
started doing
yard work so you know how that goes all
right so
okay just be very careful that he's very
delicate he breaks i'll just do it
another way he's just very delicate
but look see it's don't he's doing his
thing
no head so he says no headphones yeah
[ __ ] i definitely do think he needs a
little necklace yeah we gotta do a movie
review
we're doing a movie review this movie
check this show i can't okay i really
really likes this one
what ended up happening i was like
looking for some new [ __ ] because we
were actually
initially gonna rent one like through
the xbox and so i was looking for
recommendations
um and i made a little list and one of
the ones that was recommended on one of
these you know best horror movies so far
of 2020 was this one
and it so happened that this one was
also streaming on two beasts why don't
you have to [ __ ] pay for this stuff
yeah because god bless america so
this is actually called becoming
i'm seeing it listed as a sci-fi horror
thriller which i guess
it's sort of sci-fi i don't know i don't
know if i'd call it sci-fi but it is
kind of like a horror thriller type of
thing
um it was directed by the same guy that
directed
uh the final cut with robin williams
which actually was like a pretty good i
think that was kind of a sci-fi movie as
well
and it stars as soon as it came on the
main guy that's in it that plays the
character of alex toby kebbel i think
his name is or cabell
i was like oh where have i seen that guy
he's like so so familiar
so i looked up his imdb he was actually
in bloodshot
and he was in uh kong skull island
and he was also in that black mirror
episode uh the entire history of you
so i was like okay well that's where
i've seen that dude before but yeah
so this story is basically about
there's a guy named alex and his
girlfriend
and they are going on a road trip to
visit her parents prior to them getting
married
so they're kind of going along all these
back rows i'm not entirely sure like
where
this where it's set it's kind of like
you know sort of rural or
midwest or something like that and
they're stopping at some places along
the way now
the first place that they stop is at
this
family's place and this is apparently
alex's distant cousin and i don't think
he really knows him all that well but
his girlfriend set it up so they could
stay there
because she's like oh you know alex
doesn't have any family and i want one
of his at least one of his relatives to
be at the wedding and stuff so we're
gonna like stay with this person
now while they're at this place some
pretty weird [ __ ] starts happening
and it comes to pass this is not um a
spoiler or anything like that because
this is
basically what's in the trailer and
what's in the uh you know what's in the
description
is that there is an entity of some kind
they don't really get into what it is i
don't know if it's a demon
or something or a ghost kind of like a
doppelganger type thing
it could be but they don't really
explain like what it is or where it came
from just that it's been around for a
really long time but it essentially
needs a host body so it like hops from
person to person
and it very slowly pushes out
the personality the soul the
consciousness of the person that it
takes over and takes over that body
and this entity is a real douche um and
likes to kill people and do horrible
violent things
so in that way it reminded me of and i'm
glad that i'm not the only person that
thought of this it reminded me of if you
guys remember in 1998 there was a movie
that came out called
fallen with denzel washington where i
think that was
if i remember correctly i think that was
a demon it was like a biblical thing but
it jumped from body to body
this is kind of similar to that but they
don't really go into like a whole
religious thing like i said they don't
really explain like what this thing like
is where it came from
or why it necessarily has to do what it
does it's just a thing it's an entity
and it hops from body to body so
basically the whole story is
you know after this demon starts taking
over this guy
and he starts like acting really weird
and acting really differently
and like what his girlfriend has to do
like you know for her coming to terms
with it and all the horrible [ __ ] that
he's starting to do and him kind of like
trying to fight against the thing you
know because he doesn't really know
what's happening either
but um this i really really like this a
lot it's kind of more
on the thriller side than the horror
side it's not it's got like a lot of
violence in it in the sense of like
fighting and shooting and stabbing and
stuff but it's not like super gory
but it has like some really really great
there's some really really creepy like
scenes in this like at one point she has
like a dream
and like he's in bed and you know she
kind of like looks over at him and like
he doesn't have any features and it's
like really really creepy looking
and there's one like he's looking at his
reflection like in a dryer like his face
looks all [ __ ] up and creepy
so there's like all kinds of really
creepy [ __ ] like that but it's like it's
more thriller than horror but i would
still call it a horror movie i don't
know if i would call it sci-fi
some people have compared it to the
outsider
that series that i think is based on
that stephen king
book which i guess i haven't seen that
but i guess it's kind of like that too
but it's basically like a doppelganger
body jumping type of [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying yeah
so i've been alien who knows yeah they
didn't really go
and actually i kind of liked that i
liked that they didn't really
i mean basically it seemed like it had
it had a layer it had a house where it
kept
like you know mementos of all the people
that it had taken over
you know what i mean so it was so i
don't know like what it was exactly it
was just some kind of like
demonic and you know who else was in
this because the whole time i'm like
watching it i'm like
that looks just like jason patrick the
guy that was in
the lost boys i mean i'm sure he's been
he's been in other things too but that's
what i remembered him from because we
just saw the lost boys not too long ago
and he was in this as like this guy that
lives out in a trailer and he kind of
had put together like what was going on
because i guess the same thing kind of
happened to him at some point in the
past
and so he you know he was kind of like
the van helsing sort of figure like that
the girl kind of found and
he was kind of explaining to her what
was going on but yeah this was like
this was really good i was i was really
surprised that i came across this and it
was on 2b i didn't have to like pay to
rent it
and as i said it's on like a bunch of
best horror movies of 2020 lists
and there it was for free and i watched
it i was really into it i liked it a lot
i missed the first 20 minutes of it yeah
but it looks it seemed good
yeah you know you know from what i saw i
was like oh man it's pretty cool
but you know possibly see it again
you know yeah you probably should
because i i really like the opening
sequence of this
was like i mean i watched it and i was
kind of like oh okay you have my
interest you know what i mean because it
was just
the opening scene of it was almost kind
of like a flash
i guess it was like a flashback and it
was showing you know someone else that
had been taking over this basically like
killing their whole family and like
shooting a kid and everything
so i was kind of like all right you have
my attention
and then it goes into alex because where
he hasn't been
um infected yet and uh you know and him
kind of going and getting infected
but there's like just some really great
scenes in this one of the best scenes in
it was
this really creepy one where he goes to
like a convenience store or something
and then he's coming out and there's
this other guy in the parking lot like
trying to get in his car
and then the guy's like insisting that
it's his car and he's like
you know my name is alex ferry which is
the main character's name and it's like
you know see and then he said they're
like arguing over this car
and then this one guy who would come up
to he took said his thing he's like oh
i'm not alex ferry that's not my name
because another thing that ends up
happening too is that
while this demon or whatever it is is
pushing out your
personality it's almost kind of like
it's
it's like dispersing your personality
like out
into the so so people like will have
like snippets of your dreams and your
memories and stuff like that like people
that are in proximity to you which i
thought was a really cool idea
another movie this reminded me of and i
don't know if you guys have seen it or
not it came out in 2014 i think
and it was called honeymoon and it was
directed by lee
uh janiak i think i think is how you
pronounce her last name but it had
um what's her name bridge rose right
away from
game of thrones and the dude from penny
dreadful and they were kind of um
that was kind of a thing where they were
off in their honeymoon at this remote
cabin
and she started acting really weird like
she started forgetting [ __ ] and like she
had to like start writing
she had to write down stuff about
herself like her address and her name
and her birthday and she like started
acting really bizarro
and i'm not going to say that went in a
slightly different direction to this
that i'm not going to spoil what it was
but it gave me a similar vibe as that
in in the sense that the theme of it is
you know here's this person that you
have known for this many years this
person this person that you love
and they're suddenly not who you thought
they were and they start acting like
really different and that's like a
really scary
that's like a pretty scary theme like to
put in movies and i'm surprised that
there's not more like that
but yeah this was a really good one and
like i said it's free on
uh 2b if you want to watch it and it
gave me a really weird i was just
telling them before we started recording
it gave me a really weird dream that me
and my dad were on
a road trip and he and we were going to
stop at a hotel because it was the
middle of the night
and we passed these perfectly nice like
chain hotel like
you know nice big holiday and nice big
hilton garden in whatever
and we're passing that he's like no no
he wants the road trip experience he
wants to stay in like shitty roadside
hotels
so we're like looking for like the
shittiest roadside motel ever so he
could stay there and i was just like
what the [ __ ] dad was like indiana and
then we got lost and all this other kind
of crap
so this kind of gave me wasn't
necessarily a nightmare but it did kind
of give me like some weird [ __ ]
dreams i'd say that i'd have to see it
again to give a final
rick said honeymoon was weird as [ __ ] it
was in honeymoon that's why i don't want
to ruin that one because
i don't know i think i saw it on netflix
or shutter i don't know if it's on there
anymore
but um that was a movie that i really
don't want to spoil because
i had no idea what was going on going in
and it's way better
if you don't know you know what i mean
like because it's
it's way creepier because the whole time
i'm sitting there going what the [ __ ]
is happening you know what i mean but
it's worth it it's like it's pretty
weird
um but yeah so i think tom made my shirt
when he was drunk
why is that was it
[Laughter]
we don't usually make drunk so i don't
so i don't think we make any shirts when
we're drunk do we i don't think we ever
have why something happened to it
maybe it was crooked now or maybe i
don't know i didn't think any of them
were crooked though no
yeah they they seemed all right i don't
know i don't know
yeah he doesn't know what he said oh the
logos off center we'll send you another
one if you want
yeah yeah maybe it was i think a couple
of them were off a little bit
i don't know how many we were making at
one time i don't know when i made it
yeah what kind what which logo was it
yeah 13 o'clock one
like three inches oh [ __ ] really i don't
think they're really
that could have been three inches really
i don't know
three inches is bad that's a long way
yeah
i didn't think we were off that many
because usually usually if we mess them
up too much we just like
we wash them before we cook the ink on
there and then we'll just do another one
and we'll just do it yeah we'll send you
another one you got the collection
that's the this is the [ __ ] that was
a a group thing
because me and jenny actually lined the
[ __ ] shirt and the [ __ ] plates up
together when we do it yeah and then i
hold the thing yeah you hold it down
right so like i said that's something
i'm doing on my own if you want another
wolf engine another one though
i don't mind zack says uh you guys need
to review the sharp objects hbo show
um i actually want to see that because i
read the book not too
long ago because i reviewed it and uh
the
last comment yeah maybe your chest is
great
we've solved the mystery
oh man three inches is not good in some
situations
all right so you guys have anything you
want to no
no i just have to see this one again you
thought it looked good there right it
looked good from what i saw i
saw some scenes and i was like yeah it
was all right now there was there was a
couple
some of the scenes that i was watching
you know when that thing was teasing him
and saying [ __ ]
some of it i thought it might have been
went on a little bit too long and maybe
didn't not
quite enough action but like i said
a lot a lot of things are taste and
there's a certain tone that i like
yeah but i just have to reserve my
judgment on it
it may have been a little too slow i'd
have to see it again i didn't see it
again
yeah i mean i guess i didn't your mental
state has lots
i didn't find it that slow but yeah your
mental state at the time that you're
watching the movie has a lot to do with
it
yeah you know sometimes you'll see a
movie you don't like it you see it again
and you do like it
because you're in a different mood well
see that's why i'm always kind of like
if i see something
and it's just like i don't hate it but
it's just kind of like well whatever
like sometimes i'll give it another
chance later on because it's like like
you said maybe i just wasn't on the
right
usually usually if i don't like the
movie i hate it right i hate it right
away
yeah i've noticed and
i'm usually right about it i'll go back
and look at it again and say no this
just still sucks
sometimes i'll like a movie on first
viewing and then if i see it again i was
like well there's not a whole lot to
that movie
see i think i've had that happen more
than the opposite you i've it's very
rare that i start watching a movie and
i'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ] like in the
first like five or ten minutes usually
i'll give it a chance
um to see like if it gets better it's
like because sometimes
sometimes you have to watch the movie
through the whole thing
and then like the end like explains the
beginning you know what i mean
so sometimes you kind of have to see the
whole thing to judge it but
i mean it's very rare that i actually
watch a movie and i'm just like i don't
like this at all and i turn it off
it's rare that i'm watching a movie and
i want to work
you know at work at trying to figure it
out if you're going to get me in that
mood it's got to be [ __ ]
something fantastic it's really piqued
my curiosity
like prometheus a lot of people hated
that [ __ ] movie yeah
man i was trying to figure that movie
out for [ __ ] months and months and
months
and it turns out i got a lot of it i got
a lot of it you
guys for like a year or two afterwards i
was trying to figure that
out i got quite a bit of it it turned
out that i was right about a lot of it
yeah that's why well that's why i kind
of get because i like
movies that you have to figure out or
that like make you think about it or
like get in discussions with people
afterward
you seem to not like that but there are
exceptions to that yeah
like like prometheus because like i said
you spent like a year or two like
talking a lot of it had to do with the
tone of the movie and the way it looked
and just you know i mean the artwork
involved in the mythos that was involved
in it you know what i mean i i got kind
of pulled into it
and other people hated that movie and
it's because they were kind of taking
things at the v
at face value well they're on a space
exploration why the hell they have all
these dumb [ __ ] running the mission you
know and i'm going
yeah well it must be on purpose
you know i mean it turns out it was on
purpose yeah the robot was running
everything the robot and the replicant
a lot of people said that's not a wrap
there's a replica
you know they both it's weird because
sometimes sometimes when i read reviews
of
movies or books or whatever some of the
um
some of the complaints about it are not
valid because the person gets the
information
wrong so i'm just like well i don't know
if that's a valid
complaint because it's like that's not
what happened in the movie right or you
missed a whole
conversation in the movie that like
where they explained that
because that's something that happens a
lot i think people aren't just really
paying attention
yeah and then later they'd be like well
why did this happen and they didn't
explain that i'm like but they did
a lot of you just weren't listening a
lot of people who are in the comments
sections on
movies and you know i mean making a lot
of them are kids
well yeah and kids take things that face
them
the kids are stupid yeah they're dumb i
don't want them i don't want
kids that don't all right well ignorant
they're not used to stories in which the
characters are lying to one another
where one character lies to another one
yeah or one character says something and
they're wrong
they think that everything a character
says supports the theme of the movie and
it is
it makes the movie you know what i mean
for instance like dallas
when in in alien one when they find the
[ __ ]
dead engineer you know with the hole in
its side you know what i mean
inside the ship he says look it's
fossilized like it's been here for
thousands of years it couldn't have been
there for thousands of years
you know what i mean it's that kind of
stuff he just thought it was he's just
basically saying
it looks as though he looks like he's
not saying that i'm an expert right
and it was there for that turns out in
the lore it couldn't have been thousands
of years
yeah all right um and then also
[ __ ] in that same everybody knows
alien one
they asked the [ __ ] robot hey have
you ever seen this
ship have you seen anything like this
before he said no but he's lying
yeah he got put on the ship at the last
minute because there was this they knew
about the signal
you know i mean they were the ship was
sent out there yeah and that's
clearly [ __ ] hinted at you know in
that movie
well and that wayland industries knew
about the ship and as i said i think
some people
don't like ambiguity or they like
everything
everything like has to be spelled out
for them and i don't like that in movies
because that
to me that seems really condescending
but i don't like when movies come
the thing is though is that if you're
doing [ __ ] like that you've got to be a
master at writing a damn script
yeah you've got to be kubrick you know
or you got to be ridley scott you can
get what you can get even though he has
he has written some [ __ ] if you ask me
really scott is hit and miss
especially as he got older if you ask me
mr owl is asking who's the cutie in the
middle don't worry about all that
that's sophie i thought oh i thought you
talked about me
you're not in the middle that's sophie
have you not been here the last couple
days i guess mr owl hasn't been here for
the last few days
she was on the show starting on saturday
and she's been on like some of the
shows up connor vaslan said where did he
say it i just saw it
maybe he redacted it yeah oh no he said
i can see raider got his head back
yeah yeah put the head back on i fixed
it poor dentist
he has such a rough life
always picking on poor dennis yeah
poor dad poor serial killer
all right so oh my god the [ __ ] guy
what's the second
thing are you done talking tom all right
so i guess we'll wrap it up for today we
will probably be back tomorrow either
doing another movie review or doing a
side tracks
uh because tomorrow's wednesday right
yeah if i can find something new to what
maybe we can rent a movie tonight
all right i want to see bill and ted but
i don't want to pay 20 dollars i'm not
paying to see it that's what i'm saying
i don't want to pay 20
for it if it was like five or six
dollars okay but i'm not paying twenty
dollars you've seen the first two of
those
nope oh [ __ ] they're not for free the
first two are on
yeah i figured they would probably on
youtube but there's probably other i
mean because like i said i wrote down
some
movies that looked pretty good and we
could probably find something to watch
or you can fix them i don't know mangoes
talking
said they were j they had a jazz hands
alien jazz hands and cubby
he was it was a little bit yeah which
one what are we talking about like
jason's when he
when he came out of the box you know
what jazz hands is yeah but i'm trying
to think
when did that happen in covenant though
i remember it happening but i can't
remember what point it was in the movie
because how many times i've seen that
twice we saw in the theater
and i think we saw it again like after
you bought it because you bought it
right yeah
that wasn't a bad movie either i liked
it it's uh yeah
i think i liked prometheus better yeah
but this thing was better
the problem was is that really scott
wanted to tell an entirely different
story than alien
and they kept [ __ ] wanting wanting
him to make an alien movie
it's like fine here's a [ __ ] alien
movie yeah and then everybody was like
we don't like that one either
right this is why i'm glad i don't make
movies you can't make anybody happy
they're always gonna whine no matter
what you do
yeah that's just rule number one yeah
they weren't really those xenomorphs
they were something else
something with that robot that something
that david made yeah
spoiler alert yeah all right so we're uh
gonna wrap it up for today we didn't
even close that door look at the lights
all wear it in here yeah
oh well that's probably my fault
my take full responsibility it looks
good i know it looks okay from here
it looks good yeah yeah all right so we
will talk to you guys again tomorrow
thanks everybody for dropping by bye